austin is in gainesville florida hi
austin how are you
hi dave i'm doing good how are you
better than i deserve what's up
uh yes i've just got a quick question
for you about if it would make
sense for me and my fiance to kind of
swap around baby steps four
five and six no
uh well right now we're in baby step two
we're about to finish up next month
actually um we're 25 years old we've
been married for coming up on four
months now
congratulations yeah thank you i
appreciate it
at first she wasn't too keen on the idea
of following the baby steps and
living on runners and beans but i got
her talked into it
and um like i said we're almost done
with that and then
if my math is right we should be done
with baby step three
in about five or six months about the
end of the year excellent
excellent right now
your phone's breaking up sir try again
in here now
yeah okay yes sir right now we live in a
double-wide mobile home on some family
land
uh the land is paid for we only owe
about 69 000
per house fans right now on the mobile
home
yes sir that's a sixty thousand dollars
okay
um it was brand new i bought it only
three years ago
oh lord um and anyways we um
we know about that much on it and
i'm just kind of curious if it would
make more sense for us right now being
that we don't have a kid
she's in school or become a nurse
practitioner
if it would make sense for her and i to
go ahead
and kind of pay off the house once we
get done
with baby step three and kind of hold
off on investing for
their two and a half three years or so
or if we should just kind of follow
them as it's written and then stay off
the house while we get there
yeah no not austin
no we dave said in the beginning and we
both laughed but we were both very
serious
uh the baby steps work for a reason man
and i get
and for me i actually want to say i like
the way you're thinking you're like hey
let's let's get 100
debt free and i love that thought
process but i also want you to think
about
if you can start investing at 26 years
old
man you're setting yourself up for
wealth down the road
now i will definitely say i would get an
extra job and be investing my 15
while also going after this because
that's a depreciating
um and i could be wrong but that's a
depreciating and not as fast as the
actual brick home so
i would definitely be working very hard
to pay it off but i'm not going to do
that at
the sake of skipping over baby set four
and not investing at all
okay yes sir here's a problem you've got
what'd you pay for that uh
whenever i bought it three years ago the
total i financed the 74.
okay and so you've already lost fifteen
thousand dollars
yes sir and ten years from now what's
that mobile home worth
probably not very much without the land
and its family lands
the land is worth the land is going to
be there whether the mobile homes there
or not
yeah you're not paid you're not paying
off the land you're paying off a mobile
home right
so you have 60 000 in the middle of your
kitchen table
on fire burning
right yes sir so i think we're going to
do something else with this
with this trailer is what i would do
i want to get out i want to try to get
out of it as fast as i can
because it's going down not up
yes sir and that's kind of i guess kind
of where my uh questions been from
um longer like i said we live we live on
family land that's been in my family for
for a long long time and that's where we
that's where we intend on raising our
family
is it dated to you yes sir it is it's in
your name
yes sir how many acres uh right now
all together we've got six good for you
um
and it's kind of our dream there's some
vacant lots around us
and our dream to be able to you know pay
cash for those lots and then build a
house on that
yeah um to increase how much lane we
have what is your household income
right now we're at about a hundred and
three thousand i'm uh i'm a firefighter
and
nurse okay and then uh this this was not
on your radar so it's gonna be really
really hard for you to swallow
but i'm worried about you burning 60 000
over the next five years or 10 years
and so i would want to cut this fire
short if i were you
um and i don't know exactly how to do
this but i think i'm going to get that
trailer sold now
i might move into an apartment and then
get a construction loan and build a
house
yeah i like that dave
because i every day you keep that thing
your money's going the wrong way
right yes sir
that's that's the problem so i just i
don't i don't know what we're doing
there but
um that that's not that's not what
you're thinking because you were
thinking you're gonna ride this thing
all the way into the dirt and i just
wouldn't burn 60 000 bucks up
yeah it's too hard to come by you've
done a great job you've made a lot of
progress you've got a game plan by the
end of the year you're going to be in
good shape
and it might be that next spring uh you
start trying to get this the mobile home
sold
and you may have to put some money with
it to sell it you may end up owing more
on it than it's worth
yeah and um so
uh uh i mean you very well could be
upside down in it
uh and so i'm i'm gonna limit my losses
by getting rid of it
and that part but then you got a place
to live so i'm thinking move into an
apartment and get you a construction
loan and build a house
on the family land because homes go up
in value
the land is an independent part of this
you have a free gift of land that's
wonderful but that you got that whether
you put a mobile home on it or whether
you put a stick built home on it that's
going up in value
and so i just um yeah it's a problem
you've got
because you bought a very expensive
depreciating asset yeah
and dave i'm still new in the whole
mobile home areas
will it be more difficult to sell a
mobile home yes
very difficult wow it's uh because
because there's no land under it he's
not going to sell the land
yeah yeah he would just be selling the
mobile home but it's that
it's very i use mobile homes hard to
sell okay
and if you're not a mobile home dealer
you know i mean so
there it can be done and obviously it's
a nice pro
a nice one yeah i mean you got a lot of
money tied up in it right
but uh um but that's the problem i've
got so
anyway you you handle it however you
want sir
i think you've made really really good
progress and i think that thing's going
to be a
boat anchor around your neck while
you're trying to go swimming
as you go forward because you've got
this blessing of this fabulous piece of
land six nice acres there without any
uh and you know if you get a house built
on there and then you start saving money
like
crazy and one of those lots comes
available you could buy it and add on to
your property
and buy that with cash you know that
could be the next 10 years of your life
is just kind of building out that farm
area there
yeah so very cool it's a good it's a
good plan but i don't want to wake up 10
years from now and be living in
something that's worth nothing
while i watched it burn down